Lourde soirée putain.
Ouais, enfin c'est une soirée quoi.
Nan mais t'es sérieux mec ?
La musique est cool, les meufs sont chaudes...
Ça va être le feu !
La seule chose qui change d'une soirée à l'autre, c'est la couleur des Stan Smith.
Bah normalement t'es un gars de la night, toi.
Un gars de la night ?
Attends, tu connais la sensation d'ouvrir des bières avec ton cul ?
J'avoue...
Après y a forcément un truc positif, non ?
Ah oui c'est vrai : on sert à allumer vos clopes, on passe notre vie à se faire voler,
on sert à allumer vos clopes qui sont volées...
Ouais... Et vous êtes tout le temps dans nos poches !
Et alors ?
Bah c'est très près des couilles.
Après y a les concerts
C'est cool les concerts !
Tu parles de quoi, là ? De ce que tu fais déjà avec ton smartphone ?
Et les meufs ? "T'as pas du feu s'te plaît ?"
C'est quand même LA meilleure approche pour serrer des meufs !
Ouais ! Donc on te rend service quand on n'est pas là !
Allumer une bougie qui sent bon ?
Eh je suis pas une allumette moi !
Le feu d'artifice !
Non...C'est trop dangereux ça.
Y a forcément un truc cool !
Je sais pas... À force de se faire voler vous devez voyager.
T'as dû voir plein de choses différentes, non ?
Ça, pour voyager, on peut dire que j'ai vu du pays !
Et crois-moi parfois j'aurais préféré faire du sur-place.
Tu sais je suis pas le plus à plaindre en plus.
J'en ai même vu un avec un Jonnhy dans le dos.
C'était quand j'étais coincé là, pendant trois semaines entre les coussins d'un canapé du Macumba.
Wow.
C'est vrai que vous avez vraiment un vie de merde quoi.
Pourquoi vous vous rebellez pas ?
C'est vrai putain ! Pourquoi on se rebelle pas ?
On mérite mieux !
Eh tu sais quoi j'ai pris une décision : les choses elles vont changer.
On n'a plus de temps à perdre.
Ce soir c'est décidé, c'est moi qui te le dis, je vais lancer un combat.
Je vais lancer un appel, que tous les briquets du monde entier me rejoignent.
On va retrouver le respect qu'on nous a volé.
On va s'unir, pour combattre tous les gens qui nous ont...
Oh les gars je l'ai !
Pet... enflammé !